[Music]
wow
[Music]
welcome to the spooktacular edition
of kos and today
for our halloween surprise
i came to bring you another
then xm's holy grail
dolph castle x family
heirloom
[Music]
xm's ghost rider
[Music]
it's fitting that now
the spirit of vengeance
is home to the king
[Laughter]
let us begin shall we
[Music]
now that that's out of the way and we're
back
um you know i i thought about this
uh a million ways and uh a million
different stories
about the ghost rider and uh
he's street level but then
he is uh how can you say
like an omega level character so
him being a street level character is
those are the books that i would read a
lot when i was younger
you know daredevil um
power man iron fist when they were
separate
uh ghost rider so uh and books of that
nature
so
now that i have this ghost rider and let
me let me first let me
first give you the story of how i got
the ghost rider
so thor darth vader
of darth castle lex the show that i'm on
fridays at 9 00 pm come check us out
and he had it
and then he sold it to kmart
junior
[Music]
the man with the plan and
it stayed in the dolph castle family so
junior was changing his setup
and thor knew i was hunting for this
statue
so thor hit me and was like junior has
it for sale
so we had to ride out
literally two hours
to junior which was an absolute pleasure
junior is a stand-up guy and um
it's because of uh thor
and junior that i'm able to get this
magnificent
beast of a statue
one of the most intricate
elaborate beautiful statues
that you can ever have
and i am so happy to have it so
now that we got how i got the statue out
of the way
right and now that we
understand that it's a family a dcx
family heirloom
[Music]
now i have to tell you why this
character
is is so amazing to me this character is
so amazing to me because he has been
all over he has been uh in the fantastic
four
he has been in uh
what is it uh the avengers uh he has
been in the
secret avengers um
this character has had many iterations
from the iconic johnny blaze
to danny ketch
to robbie reyes
[Music]
and i thought at first
because of the bike that this character
was actually the johnny blaze
uh ghost rider sadly mistaken
this is not johnny if you look at the
boots
spikes wrist spikes shoulder spikes
that tells you this is danny cash
and i know the bike doesn't indicate so
because daddy cash had a different bike
if you look at my old video
of uh ghost rider
the one sixth scale line that i have
with a one-time a one-time
line that i do have of him um that
is the danny ketch bike all right
so bikes aside
i said to myself how strong is ghost
rider
well he went up against world breaker
hulk
and he could have actually stopped him
but remember his penance still only
works on those
who are guilty of a sin and a crime and
the hulk wasn't
so wouldn't work on him so couldn't go
into that fight
and i had a couple of early on sal
business ghost rider fights with the
hulk
where he had teamed up with a couple of
other riders to take down the hulk and
you know hell blaze fire was bothering
the hulk
um i was gonna talk about that then i
said nah
um so many different stories
space ghost rider i could have did that
not a fan of that
so i settled on
when gold's rider was part of a failed
team
called the champions 1975
this book comes out hercules black widow
iceman ghost rider
is part of this team and
yeah that's an amalgamation of
weird proportions right i mean stand
alone those are all
stand-up characters right you have
hercules for the strength
you have iceman for you know powers you
have ghost rider for his powers
you have um a black widow
you know for her tactical abilities you
would think that it would work but it
was too many writers and stuff that was
on and off with the books started off
strong
but couldn't keep up and i i was one of
those people that you know had
almost every issue i think they had like
17 issues i had
every issue of the i believe the
upstairs
and i only tuned in for the ghost rider
like
i would only tune in for more lutino
with spiderman with the ghost rider
because i'm such a ghostwriter fan
i don't know what he represents he just
represents i mean i
literally if you saw somebody going down
the street
on fire on a bike crazy
just absolutely crazy nicholas cage
nailed him in the movie
and i thought nicolas cage did a
wonderful job playing him
um you know as much crap as nicolas cage
gets i salute the man for bringing this
character to
life and giving me the ghost rider so
you know it's not a super story i got to
tell you today it's just so much
admiration and
and there's so many stories to be told
with this character like when he teamed
up with demon hell
hellstrom um damien hellstrom
uh that's the the the son of satan i
used to read that book when i was
younger
right so this guy
is incredible so let's get into the
statue
and from the outset you can tell
the flames are multifaceted
like from the base from the base there's
skulls in the base there's rocks in the
base
there's flames all in the base if you
can see it
it's yellows there's oranges
there's hues of gray and some black
and it looks like fire like he's riding
through hell and as you get to the fire
on the wheels
the wheels indicate uh uh
crazy fire as if you can see that
looks insane absolutely insane
then you get to the to the bike itself
and you get to the chassis
and you can see through the chassis how
look how intricate the bike base is this
is heavy
resin heavy metal it's
beautiful the scope on it is immaculate
you the devil horns that's in the front
of the actual face of the bike is crazy
you can see his boots his boots and the
spikes
is is is an insane
the way he grips the chain that wraps
around his shoulder
that goes around the bike all the way up
to the front of the bike
to shoot off a rocket like
a pincer it's insane
[Music]
his eyes like you can see deep into the
eye
sockets into the back of his head so you
can see like the penis stare
when he's trying to to to to make you
uh like what would they say a come to
god
moment his head is on fire so you can
see the motion
he's popping a whaley
this is an incredible statue
done incredibly
look at it all the way
100 percent fantastic
statue that i am so happy
to be the new proud owner of if you look
at the leather
and stitching in the back
incredible incredible
and on the license plate it tells you
the number ghost rider that you have
well i have ghost rider xm number eight
so this is the eighth one that came off
the line
that i received and i am
so incredibly happy
to have this statue now
being that i did this statue
a little bit differently all right so
it's going to be
a lot of pictures because this statue
comes in 19 pieces
in a huge gigantic box and it comes in
two
layers so what i did was i took pictures
and it built up all the way through i'm
going to give a video run through
because
normally i have it on
my uh mobile lazy susan
but this statue
is too valuable
[Music]
too much of a iconic
piece for me to even be
thinking about putting it on a motorized
unit
in the art print the art print
depicts this statue
completely i love xm for this
i love the fact that they actually give
you an art print
so you can just get a laminated and
when you put your statue up you can put
it in the background
and you can see where the artist was
going with the statue
well this is a part in the video
where i'm gonna ask you to like follow
subscribe and hit that join button
hit that joy button you know where that
joint button is
that join button is right there at the
bottom so hit that join button
and become a member of the realm so
while you're in the realm you can get a
chance to see
me do the hot chip challenge or when i
got the tattoo on my chest from will me
hood wait a second both of those are
from will be like
will me
anyway go to lords of gaming.net
where we have a ton of opinion pieces a
ton of writers
doing everything for this next
generation that's coming up with these
xbox and this playstation 5 this stuff
is really incredible and also nintendo
is out here doing their thing
also watch the last word with all
cognito and ibontes
this week they had rick cackus on yo
go check out that show it's amazing
they're doing that thing destiny is
about to get really crazy because it's
going to 60 frames per second
and i can't wait to get cog back yes
that's right
he's leaving pc alone and he's coming
back home
to xbox see you god
see you soon so stick around
watch all the pictures and also i have a
little surprise
hey guys this is halloween
and i wanted to do something special for
you so this is the special treat that i
had for you
and it's a fantastic statue i hope you
enjoyed it
and i hope you guys stay safe remember
check all the candy that you get if you
happen to go out trick-or-treating
and make sure that all the kids are safe
enjoy your halloween
have a safe day and see you next week
where i bring you something
that's making
my peter tingle stay
collected
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
i rule
[Music]
you